today we are unboxing the brand new
Apple watch I'm trying to contain my
excitement because this thing is so
beautiful this is the 40 millimeter gold
version I've even got my gold knife
ready to unbox she's got a few Apple
watch bands as well I don't even need my
knife it has a little pull tab well I've
got the knife out so we're gonna use it
oops what's this wow what an experience
oh gosh how can I do it again it was so
cool I just it was like this it just
opened up it's like Hello
look how cool this looks so here's the
front of the box let's open it up that
our paperwork you got our charging brick
Abelar charger and the app watch itself
right inside look at this little teeny
tiny case that it comes in oh wow
[Music]
this is probably the coolest thing ever
what a cute little protector matches the
tennis so perfectly so they have the
Apple watch band separately beautiful
gold it's kind of like a rosy brass ish
color because when I think of gold I
think of this knife color and this here
they are next to each other the ceramic
version it is kind of sad that they're
not making the ceramic Apple watches
anymore these have been so durable and
really really great I just love a look
of it but this wow let's take a quick
little time to travel back to some of
the previous versions of the Apple watch
the first Apple watch that I got was
this one it's a 38 millimeter this is
the aluminum one it looks just like it
looks in this floor then from there they
announced the stainless steel so I
thought hmmm I should probably get a
bigger one that makes sense
wow it's so big it's freakin real big at
a time I was thinking yells is 38 real
tiny well now I'm thinking holy crap 42
then they announced that they had a rose
gold so of course I got that one in the
42 millimeter and this poor little thing
it definitely took a fall but that's
okay I guess it's okay now I just keep
it as a memento oh god it looks good
this is rose gold this is pink so after
that the series 2 came out this is the
ceramic of course I've at hae 42 it's
definitely really enjoying this large
watch base the white looks so fresh so
freakin fresh and then when the series 3
came out I got 2 different sizes I got
the 42 which I planned on keeping and
they also got the 38 just to test out I
think I might like the 38 I can't go
back to a 38 do you know why I have
invested a lot into Apple watch bands
and they're all for a 42 well it turns
out that I ended up really liking the 38
much better so here it is so this is my
current watch this is the 38 with
cellular and now here we are with a
brand new series 4 there's a bunch of
new differences in this one so the back
of the new Apple watches is
nation of ceramic and the sapphire
crystal they now move the microphone
next to the digital crown and over here
is the speakers and they actually made
the speakers 50 percent louder one of
the reasons that I love my Apple watch
so much is obviously I can get
notifications but the health benefits
for this thing is really what I use it
most for I also like knowing now that if
my heart rate happens to elevate or drop
to low like Apple watch will let me know
that rhymes I should be a poet it'll
also be able to tell irregular
heartbeats and now with a new ECG you'll
be able to get a very clear reading on
your heart just by holding here for 30
seconds when you're inside the ECG app
jaw it's starting up so this is my old
phone I haven't actually entirely set up
this one yet so I'm just gonna sync it
for the time being I love that it asks
you which risk that you're wearing it on
left or the right most people do wear
watches on their left hand but because I
write with my left hand I wear it on the
right
I'm also weird I like to wear the
digital crown on the left more on the
health benefits you can now track and
watch ios5 hiking and yoga I'm about to
actually head to a yoga class right now
so I'm gonna test this out one of the
biggest difference is the sizes so they
now come in a forty millimeter and a 44
millimeter so previously it was 38 and
42 but the crazy thing is the actual
overall size when you're looking at it
or you have it on your wrist it doesn't
feel much larger because they extended
the screen all the way to the edges and
they've even rounded the corners it
makes this screen feel like I'm watching
your freaking IMAX movie this is the new
40 millimeter version and this is
Jenna's old 38 millimeter the actual
watch itself is thinner and the screen
size now is the same size as the 42
millimeter which was the previous
biggest version let's check out some of
these new Apple watch bands
it says 40 millimeters now but the good
news is that all of the previous watch
bands that you have are still compatible
with the new one oh it's a hibiscus
sport loop I love the hibiscus refresher
for the Starbucks
oh yeah Color Me freakin impressed the
thing that I've been worried about it's
not even that big of a concern is
because the gold I'm very particular
about color combinations well okay it's
actually not bad the nice salmon
these I've just been getting into the
sport loop for whatever reason I kind of
avoid getting them but they're so so ok
this looks great I'm in love with this
color combination these are basically
like my two favorite colors like a
salmon tank and a rose gold this is a
lavender band and not sure how the
lavender and gold to look that's one
thing that I did like about the white I
feel like everything matched it oh hello
lavender and the gold look good too
vanilla knees Luke will be reserved for
fancy functions good I'm so proud I mean
I don't know why I'm surprised
okay so now that my ever watch is all
set up I'm gonna go find my sister and
we are going to continue testing this
thing out I still have to show you guys
all the new watch faces but for bats I'm
going to go to the yoga class right now
and see how that whoa the haptic
feedback feels so cool so not used to
that
[Music]
so it's a little chilly in here but
we're now in the yoga studio and I'm
going to be testing out new Apple watch
some of my most favorite features in
watch OS 5 is that you can track hiking
and yoga I've said this so many times
but it's my favorite watch OS 5 update
so that isn't something that is
exclusive to the new watches if you guys
update your watch OS you will also have
access to these as well so you can see
here when you go into the workout
section there's yoga strength training
other so now let's test out the yoga and
get some cool b-roll of me acting like
I'm actually doing a yoga class right
now I'm not I did one earlier today
[Music]
so that was my fake little yoga workout
we're gonna end it and this gives you
your total time your active calories and
your average heartbeat all of my friends
who are friends with me on my Apple
watch and the health app they'll get a
notification that I just completed my
goal which is really about it I hope
that they don't see that one because
there was only seven minutes of yoga
yoga there is another thing where you
can challenge your friends should I send
a competition notice to marques and
Jonathan this digital crown is now an
electrical heart sensor so that allows
you to take an ECG reading of your heart
this is just recently FDA cleared so
it's not available yet but it will be
available in a software update coming
very soon so I'm not a runner but if you
are there are some new running features
that you guys might be into so you can
choose your target pace and then your
watch will alert you if you're ahead or
behind it that pace also new is when you
raise your wrist it'll tell you how many
steps per minute that you have so let's
give this a quick test and see see how
good I am in running which I'm not ready
[Music]
okay let's end this I ran for five
minutes 53 seconds forty four three
eight miles winnin calories average pace
fifteen twenty thirty Wow I'm not
winning any awards with that one I know
21 steps per minute average heart rate
128 weather so insects grace it's very
nice we should go outside you know so
we're now outside and we're gonna test
out the hike I can't really say that
this is a very extensive hike but at
least we'll be able to see the elevation
features let's go
it is so beautiful
so we finished a mic it was probably
well it wasn't very long but I got the
prompt to end my workout because one of
the newest features is if you forget to
stop your workout it'll say hey finish
your workout we hiked for 14 minutes
total distance 0.26 miles every 118
calories look at that let's tell all my
friends
you went hiking for the first time with
the workout app business I hope everyone
is so proud of my workout now I want to
send a competition request to Marquez
I'm inviting mkbhd to a 7-day
competition invite he has 48 hours to
accept what if he doesn't accept my
competition I hear a drone
[Music]
they announced the walkie-talkie feature
and watch OS v @ w DC and since then I
have been patiently awaiting so here we
are talk with friends Apple watch -
Apple watch contacts you ad can talk to
you whatever your set - available I'm
inviting with my friend Dakota see you
else I can add you don't have watching
us 5 yet going to invite Jonathan mkbhd
invited edy oh my god
I think hello am I doing this right
I'm filming right now and I just got
this oh my gosh this is an authentic
reaction this is so cool can you talk
back to me or is that it hey hey keep it
I'm waiting for a response back did you
get my competition request I hope you're
ready it has to be super real-time
because as I was talking he basically
responded two seconds later and he's
across the country oh so excitable
walkie-talkie it's such a simple feature
am I overreacting no I'm excited
let's go finish filming this video does
gonna take me 500 hours at it now all
you have to do if you want to activate
Siri is just raise it text Jenna is Eric
and tell her that she's doing a really
great job filming this video for me and
I appreciate her she is nice and the
best sister EVER
exclamation point okay did you get it
yeah
Wow I can't wait for you to get
walkie-talkie we're gonna be having so
much fun
Maddy I wish you had walkie-talkie do
you remember when you were a baby and I
put an apple watch on you for size
comparison the Apple watch is also now
50% louder so you'll be able to hear
cereal to hear phone calls better
actually let me test it out call Edie
Palumbo hey how about you set the camera
oh it's calling me back I declined it I
have a button I pushed the wrong button
hi sorry I'm making a video and I went
to answer it but I don't ever use like
making phone calls very often so I hit
the wrong button instead of answer and I
hung up on you how do I sound do I sound
good this is a video I'm I am talking to
you for my Apple watch really hold on
the dog just stole some chapstick oh
gosh Nick come here hate chapstick boy
so it sounds good new it sounds good
he's looking around he's confused so
I've been trying out the Apple watch now
for a few days and I'm having so much
fun with it I would say that my favorite
thing is how incredible the screen size
is so this is now the smallest version
of the Apple watch that they have I've
enjoying some of the new activity
sharing features I've got a competition
now going on with my sister Jenna and
marques the walkie-talkie is so cool I
think it's probably one of my new
favorite features and I'm excited to
test that out with some more of my
friends who I'm waiting for them to
accept my requests well thank you guys
so much for watching hope you guys enjoy
this let me know if there's any of the
things that you would like me to test
out on the Apple watch or any other
videos that you'd like to see me make
here whether it's Apple related or not I
am always down to read your suggestions
and take them
chessy later
[Music]